hello everybody who are watching this
video clip of my introduction to our
research spreadsheet intelligence for
Excel ideas I'm sure hung from a
researcher from Microsoft Research Asia
in Beijing we are the data knowledge
intelligence group we started research
on spreadsheet intelligence since about
five years ago and in the past two years
we have been in close collaboration with
Excel and we shipped ideas excel ideas
in Excel together which is a one-click
intelligence that empowers you to
understand your data with high level
visual summaries and insightful patterns
now let me go to the first demo about
ideas in Excel this is a worksheet and
it has some sales data about bicycle the
data is in the form of a
multi-dimensional table it has five date
fields three of them are dimensions and
two of them are measures for example the
ear data field is a temporal dimension
the category and product are two
categorical dimensions while sales and
rating are measures now let me just a
single click on ideas button the
intelligent service will help you
understand your data for example these
are two high level summary analysis
sales by product rating by year and
category and also there are inside for
patterns for example sales increase over
year and also accessories has noticeably
higher sales across all the categories
for this kind of insights it's not easy
for user just to discover them from the
raw data and it costs users some time
and effort to figure them out if user
interested he or she can click the
button to see more for example here is
sales and reading appear highly
correlated with one outlier and quite
often the alpha here might be more
interesting and also we realized that
reading also increased over years and if
user feel interested he or she can click
insert button and the insights will be
inserted to the grid
a user can use it directly as the
analysis result in the report or he or
she can conduct some follow-up analysis
based on right so this is a demo for
ideas in Excel to enable such a
one-click
intelligence is never easy there is a
pipeline of underlying tasks with Grand
Challenges let me explain them a little
bit first after I click the ideas button
we need to automatically detect all the
tables on the sheet to be analyzed I
will get back to this very soon after a
table detection at the second step for
each detected table we will need to
automatically recognize their table
structure quite often human user create
tables in various structures that can be
very beautiful and very human friendly
but I have to say such kind of human
friendly tables are often not a machine
friendly which means machine can
difficult can hardly understand the
structure of such kind of tables so
based on the recognized table structure
we need to automatically transform the
data into some canonical form so that
machine can automatically process them
at a third step we need to automatically
understand the meta data for example in
this data set we need to know which
diffuse are dimensions which diffuse our
measures for the dimensions which ones
are temporal which ones are categorical
and four measures what's their default
aggregation function for example for
sales people usually do some but for
readings we rarely some readings up but
we usually do average all right
last but not least we will go to
analysis recommendation and insights
mining it usually have has a very high
computational complexity or with a huge
search space as well as all the
challenges in modeling the semantics in
the analysis alright so in this demo
next step I will focus on one piece of
it to exemplify our technology suite
which is the table sense for table Ridge
detection let's go to the demo at first
I would say table detection is very
important
yet very challenging it is important
because just imagine in this kind of
one-click intelligence without a table
detection the whole experience cannot be
fully automated also without this kind
of technology user may have to manually
select the exact range of a table even
though user want to do that for some
other important scenarios it is almost
impossible to do that for example mobile
and cloud for mobile many mobile devices
are just a very small screen so it will
be very difficult for user to specify
exact boundary of tables on very small
screen also in the cloud when we want to
do some offline analysis against large
scale of data there is no chance for
user to do interaction and specify each
table in each file so that's why table
detection is very important and now
where this demo you see it is also very
challenging this is the table sense demo
I click the table sense button so this
is the detecting result we highlight the
exact table range with our title without
full note in this example it shows that
for some sometimes used user may insert
some white space inside a table which
challenges the continued
inside a table that can confuse machine
and challenge that type of detection
task this is another example and this
example I would say is more challenging
than previous one it seems that there
are four pieces however semantically
they are in one table sometimes the the
table are not well formatted so it's
even challenging for human human user
need to spend a lot of effort and
attention to correctly identify what's
the exact boundary of a table another
example so in this example table has
more complex structure I just go through
more examples so this is also an
interesting example so actually mmm
there are three tables it's a it's very
visually confusing right sometimes user
can put a lot of table on a single sheet
for example this one
okay I will not enumerate all the tables
one by one so let's go back to this part
beyond this pipeline of fundamental tax
tasks actually in the past five years we
have accumulated a rich repository of
Technology suite for example it also
includes automatic table formatting and
data and presentation defect detection
and automated from formula refactoring
so if you feel interested about our
research and Technology more details can
also be checked out from our project
website
aka mas slash spreadsheet intelligence
thank you